hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
early on in his piece technologies of
the self michelle foucault
is going to talk about two
key precepts or you might think of them
as guiding
ideas and the relationship between them
in technologies of the self and how they
are understood and applied
this is in the section the development
of technologies of the self
and then he takes it up again in the
section that he just titled summary and
there's also a couple insights from a
little bit later on in the essay that we
want to
bring up in order to understand the
relationship between these
these two precepts so so what are these
two precepts
um he tells us that there there's two of
them that are
particularly important and that
one comes to supplant the other so the
first one is
epi malaysia salto or how to taking care
of the self we're going to flush this
concept out it also includes the notion
of
concern and the notion of doing
something not just like feeling uh
something about yourself but or thinking
something about yourself but
but doing something so there's that and
then there's the famous delphic
that is from the oracle adelphi maxim
gnothy saltone
know yourself and there's there's a
tendency as he points out
in philosophy and he's thinking about
the philosophy of the you know french
at his time but i think this would apply
very well to the way that we teach
philosophy
and talk about or celebrate philosophy
on a very superficial level in our
own time we really do prioritize this
gnothy salto know yourself the
unexamined life
is not worth living is the catchphrase
that we usually
associate with it with a figure of
socrates and
you know as for co rightly points out
any attentive
study of even the most basic documents
like the apology
of you know in depicting socrates from a
platonic perspective not
even to mention xenophon's perspective
would show us that this is just one
little piece
and that care of the self is actually
much more important
so how do we understand these
in relation to each other so foucault
goes on and he says
among the greeks these practices in late
antiquity but also in
early antiquity took the form of a
precept to take care of yourself to take
care of the self to be concerned to take
care of yourself
and he said that this precept of the
care of the self and in french
susie de soi right uh the same sort of
interesting linguistic things going on
there so you see concern
care self there's a reflexivity
to this right it is the self
that is caring for the self
and so there's there's a sort of subject
object at the same time
he says this was for the greeks one of
the main principles of cities
one of the main rules for social and
personal conduct and for the art of life
for us now the notion is rather obscure
and faded
now you know it's interesting because
really for the greeks was this the main
thing
we have to be a little bit skeptical of
that for
two good reasons one is that if you've
read a lot of greek literature
no there's a lot of different competing
principles at play right
uh and a little bit later on he's going
to tell us that socrates
was telling his uh countrymen
in athens hey you are paying attention
to the wrong things you need to pay
attention to the self
and presumably he wouldn't have had to
say that if it really was like
the guiding principle but let's go along
with fukofur for the moment right
he says without doubt our philosophical
tradition has over
emphasized the delphic principle
gnothy sautone know yourself you know
when
we ask people what is the most important
moral principle in ancient philosophy
that's usually what people bring up
and he says it's overemphasized that and
forgotten the care of the self the
delphic principle
was not an abstract one concerning life
it was technical advice
a rule to be observed for the
consultation of the oracle
know yourself meant and now here he's
really going off a little bit into
interpretation
uh that that could be wrong on this
know yourself meant do not suppose
yourself to be a god other commentators
suggest it meant be aware of what you
really ask when you come to consult the
oracle
and you know okay these are plausible
ideas
it can also be extended as it was to you
know you should
you should know who you are so we've got
these two
could be competing could be
collaborating principles
care for yourself know yourself both of
which involve
this reflexive relation either of action
or understanding
of the self to itself so centering on
the the person
both of these are connected with each
other clearly connected with each other
the question we have to frame then is
well what should be
the prioritization do you focus first on
care of the self and then through that
arrive
at knowing oneself or
do you say well you've got to know
yourself first
and then you can begin to care for
yourself and you know the the answer to
this
again if we delve into texts and
traditions
is not quite as universal as saying well
there's like you know cultures and times
where one has a clear priority and where
the
you know there's others where the the
other has a clear priority
but we can distinguish things maybe on a
continuum
another key thing that he brings up here
is should these be understood
as principles or as ongoing practices
you know knowing yourself is that
something you can do
in a period of time and now it's kind of
fixed and you know
who you are not just in a general way
like knowing human nature but knowing
the specificity of yourself or is even
that an ongoing process
that may change over time definitely
care of the self
has to be an ongoing process not
merely something that you say that
sounds
cool right that's not care of the self
and
there is a really interesting point here
there's a lot of key insights actually
one of these is that
in like he says in the socratic
dialogues in xenophon hippocrates the
neoplatonous tradition
one had to be concerned with oneself one
had to occupy oneself with oneself
before the delphic principle of knowing
oneself was brought into action there
was a subordination of the second
principle to the former
he gives some examples of that one of
those very examples is socrates saying
to his countrymen
who presumably are not doing this i want
you to be concerned
with yourself not just with your
reputation not just with you know
making a bunch of kids that are going to
like pass on your line
not just with making money or whatever
it happens to be
right so there's a couple other key
insights
one that i think is particularly
important
especially in a time when
a lot of our discourse about the self
has become
you might say bound up with the
discourse of
a secularized mindfulness
tradition that is there
by the way in not just non-western
philosophies
like buddhism where it's drawn from and
then they take all the buddhist content
out of it but but also in the west for
example
in the stoic's conception
of attentiveness right or
even the sort of care of the self that
we're talking about
here so he he tells us that
here we go epimelasty expresses
something more
much more serious than the simple fact
of paying attention so there's there's a
lot more going
on there you do have to pay attention
you do have to have attentiveness
the stoics actually like epictetus
suggests carrying it out all the time
um but that's not enough that's that's
not a full care of the self he says
it involves various things taking pains
with one's holding
and one's health it's always a real
activity
and not just an attitude it is used in
reference to the activity
of a farmer tending his fields his
cattle and his house
or to the job of the king and taking
care of his city and citizens
or to the worship of ancestors or gods
or as a medical term to signify the act
the fact of
caring so that that's one key thing it
can't just be reduced to paying
attention or mindfulness or you know
even
attentiveness like stock pro
another thing that he says a little bit
later on is that the care of the self
is a widespread activity it's not
abstract advice but a widespread
activity
a network of obligations and
services to the soul so this
is quite important then the third i
think really helpful
way of understanding what he's talking
about here is that
the new care of the self involved a new
experience
of the self and he's saying this at a
particular point in time
but we could say this about what it was
that
philosophical and
medical and theological
slash practical you know monastic
discourses were doing with these
new cares of the self new aspects of the
soul perhaps even you could say
new aspects of human nature itself
are being revealed to us in in ourselves
and that's why it's so important to read
authors who we may not uh agree with
or want to take on so we can see what it
is that they actually
discovered being there right now he also
talks about
there being a shift a very interesting
shift in
modernity to focusing on self-knowledge
but not self-knowledge in the ancient
sense much more
abstract self-knowledge and
uh prioritizing that over the care of
itself even to the degree that maybe the
care of the self winds up being
submerged or being forgotten now
why does that come about he talks about
two
main different um
things going on that that he sees as
particularly
connected to this i don't know that this
is
you know a full account but i don't know
that we actually need a full account at
this
point he says there are several reasons
why know yourself has obscured take care
of yourself the
the first he says there's been a
profound transformation in the moral
principles of western society
we find it difficult to base rigorous
morality and austere principles on the
precept we should give more care to
ourselves than to anything else in the
world
we're more inclined to see taking care
of ourselves as an immorality
as a means of escape from all possible
rules and he says this is an inheritance
from
you know christian morality and you know
it is largely in line
with some other discourses
on the nature of modern morality and we
can say
certainly that there's a tendency to
view concern with the self is just
you know bear egoism and we don't want
that instead we want something that's
more
other centered right but it could be
that we totally misunderstood
that i mean you can see a great example
of this
is the um you know late 20th century
early 21st century discourse on
is aristotle an egoist or an altruist
and the answer is
blah these categories
don't even work uh they're they're
they're a misconception
any time that you approach aristotle
with that in mind you might generate
something interesting for that discourse
but you've totally misunderstood
aristotle particularly when you're
looking at his discussions of you know
friendship and
stuff like that so that's you know
that's part of what's going on
he also says another thing about this we
inherit
a secular tradition that sees an
external law the basis for
morality how then can respect for the
self be the basis
for morality were the inheritors of a
social morality that seeks rules for
acceptable
behavior in relations with others since
the 16th century criticism
of established morality has been
undertaken in the name of importance of
recognizing and knowing the self
so it's difficult to see the care of the
self as compatible
with morality and he says really what
we've got here is a morality of
asceticism
so it's it's not going to recognize
anything
like a robust care of itself is good the
second is that the focus on
self-knowledge in what foucault is
calling
theoretical philosophy here he has in
mind
he talks about you know husserole for
example because you know all of us are
reading
husserl and descartes okay more people
read descartes
than visceral but there is this focus
on consciousness on the
knowing subject epistemology his first
philosophy he is right about that right
and we could equally target hume or lock
or much of you know contemporary
philosophy that's oriented around these
points
the human subject in much contemporary
philosophy is very very abstract right
uh compared to the human subject in
ancient and medieval and
even some early modern philosophy like
you could think about pascal for example
so this focus
he says on knowledge knowledge of the
self as the thinking
subject takes on an ever increasing
importance as the first step in a theory
of knowledge and so this obscures once
again the care of the self because the
care of the self essentially becomes
irrelevant
the the self is just this concrete
particular individual and we don't
really care that much
about that as a matter of fact if we
want to know things in philosophy we
need to get away from
the particularities of who we are and
how we're constituted
so you know there's there's something
here to this
and we can say that foucault in in you
know the broad sense is probably right
that there's
too much emphasis on knowing the self
and not enough emphasis on you know the
robust possibilities
of a care for the self how does this tie
back with technologies of the self
both of these would be connected with
technologies of the self would they not
um as a matter of fact knowing yourself
is important but
care of the self is how those
technologies
are in fact deployed expanded
and you know replicated you could say
you